[Music]
ternoon everybody and welcome to a
technical deep dive into service mesh
networking the session today is going to
be in four parts Act one service mesh
networking in which I'll provide an
overview of the service mesh and
described a role which the Envoy proxy
plays in the service mesh data plane in
part to my colleague Arun we'll talk
about Google's managed control plane for
the service mesh traffic director this
was mentioned in the keynotes yesterday
and at a fantastic session by projector
which I recommend watching on youtube if
you haven't finally Larry Peterson CTO
of open networking foundation will
describe some novel use cases for the
service mesh at l2 and l3 wherein
telecommunications industry the service
mesh concepts have been applied finally
we'll wrap up with some QA by way of
introduction I'm Harvey took I'm a
Googler I work on envoy weave platform
issues at Google
I'm also an open source contributor in
envoy and a maintainer and I'm super
passionate about envoy and its role in
the service mesh why do we care about
the service mash and envoy part of this
is driven by this move towards micro
services this is pretty uncontroversial
this industry-wide shift that's
undergoing right now from you know
managing your applications like pets to
cattle or in the case of this slide and
adorable a basket full of puppies and
you know this has brought huge wins for
development velocity orchestration
making our systems more dynamic but on
the other hand there is a perceived an
actual cost in terms of complexity at
the networking level enter the service
mesh in the service mesh we abstract
away all this network plumbing and the
nuts and bolts and it said we start
reasoning at the granularity of
applications in micro services we think
in terms of application security service
discovery and observability how does
this
work well one common topology for the
service mesh is the sidecar proxy we
inject into a container running
alongside applications an additional
process of binary which is essentially
the Gateway to the service mesh for that
application it contains all this sort of
network function goodies that are
required to participate in the service
mesh from service discovery to
authentication authorization rate
limiting tracing and so on all these
network functions are factored out of
the individual applications so that they
don't need to be reimplemented multiple
times in each different language or
framework or micro service that you
might be writing there are alternative
topologies we won't talk too much about
them today but just to give you an idea
you could also imagine running a library
which contains this functionality and
this is typify by G RPC lb which is a
fantastic example of client-side
lookaside load balancing where instead
of hopping through an additional process
your stay remain in process and you use
your RPC libraries essentially there are
your gateway to the service mesh this
has advantages in terms of orchestration
and reduced performance overhead another
example alternative in-service mesh that
is sometimes seen is the middle of proxy
configuration in which legacy
applications in brownfields deployments
are bridged to the service mesh via an
external proxy they may not be running
in containers you can tree link these
against some library to provide the
service mesh capabilities envoy is the
leading open source service mesh proxy
it runs as a sidecar proxy as we saw a
few slides ago and we're going to just
dive into some of the details of what
envoy is about so a good starting place
is what is envoy concretely and if we
look at its architecture its design
philosophy it's a code base built for
performance predictability and low
overhead it's written in C++
it's a midsize project it's designed
it's written in such a low-level
language because we care about things
like tail latency and minimizing
overhead on the fast path and the data
plane we care about reducing memory
consumption when running in a docker
environment we also care about security
and reliability being in a low-level
language it's also vital that you then
apply best practices when it comes to
software engineering we have incredibly
high test coverage I develop a community
which is borrower it's best practices
from companies like Google lyft in the
industry to produce reliable and stable
and secure software envoy it's not just
a proxy and in few slides time I'm going
to talk about envoys role as a platform
so keep that in mind it does have a lot
much of sort of goodies built into it
including advanced load balancing and
health checking algorithms support for
modern protocols first so it doesn't
have too much legacy craft from ancient
network protocols and integrates well
with other folks in empires in the
service message infrastructure space
systems such as Prometheus or data dog
or Zipkin so we've covered like what
envoy is and then the question is like
who is envoy what is this community
who's behind it who uses envoy and
production this slide sort of captures
some of the contributions to envoy ahead
of tray by a number of lines of code
envoys Providence is left it was created
by the project founded Matt Klein at
left to solve the service mesh
networking needs of left and was open
sourced roughly two and a half years ago
since then there's been a significant
uptake in interest in particular from
Google and this long tail of developers
Google's the green bar you can see here
that second from the left lifts the pink
and there's a huge number of companies
which make our community so awesome
today they've contributed all kinds of
integrations and improvements to the
core envoy proxy these are you know
traditional enterprise companies
there says providers and their startups
if we look here it just like the lines
of code over time clearly on boys become
much larger but it's also become much
more diverse in terms of its
contributors we start on the left back
in the end of 2016 with just lift and
that sea of pink in the 2017 in the
middle you can see Google and lyft were
the main contributors and the rights the
community is now pretty well balanced
between this long tail of the rest of
the community Google and left homeboy is
used much more widely in production than
justice developer man's community though
you can see here some familiar brand
names you'll find on the Envoy landing
page for folks who are running on boy in
production and are proud to say so
there's also a huge number of other
folks who are using envoy in these kinds
of roles for example SAS or cloud
infrastructure providers or cloud
service providers who might be using it
either directly or who might be using it
because envoy is embedded in other
products envoys for example ships with
sto and anyone using sto is it by
virtually using envoy why is envoy being
so successful and being used so widely
well part of this is because envoy is a
platform it's versatile it can meet the
needs of various use cases and be
reconfigured as needed it be this
platform like nature arises from two
aspects of envoy first its control plane
which is built around a set of open G
RPC based protocols called XTS allowing
envoy to integrate first with well-known
control planes like SEO and traffic
director but also with you know custom
in-house network infrastructure that
might need in inter envoy to fit within
the its existing configuration pipeline
almost data plane is also extensible
that is all the traffic flowing through
envoy can be interposed on by extensions
that you can write and that the
community has written to add in all
kinds of functionality this slide lists
about rough
a dozen or so plus extensions that exist
today an envoy
these range from the meat and potatoes
of its TCP and HTTP filters these
filters provides the ability to do
things like transcoding between
different protocols let's say G RPC and
Jason rest or to apply additional
control over the stream of traffic for
example right limiting a false injection
there's also sort of advanced extension
features for things like replacing
Transport Security we actually have a
current PR for introducing an extension
point for hardware security modules home
voice extensions go beyond just the data
plane it's there its extensions
community exists for things like
monitoring so you can integrate with
pretty much any monitoring system that
exists homeboy also ships with batteries
included so it already has integrations
with many of the systems that you might
care about for example Prometheus today
extensions are written in C++ primarily
and you statically link them against the
Envoy binary but there's actually a very
promising trend which we're seeing right
now in which extensions are being
offered in dynamic languages like lure
and injected at runtime so envoy via the
control plane this makes envoy a
programmable data plane and in the
future we debate that web assembly
support will arrive and will be able to
basically write extensions in any
language that you want and deliver it
dynamically to a running Envoy process
its control plane is built around this
alphabet soup of protocols which we call
XDS these sub protocols allow things
like service discovery load balancing
assignments load reporting delivery of
route configuration health checks and so
on there canonically defined and built
around G RPC streaming and protocol
buffers that we have rests in yeah Mel
and Jason variants for folks who prefer
those technologies they have a range of
consistency models depending upon the
use case and how your control playing
and management servers are configured we
view these protocols there's not just
being on voice control plane but being a
sort of a lingua franca for network
proxies in general that is that they're
the universal data plane API for elf for
l7 once you have said of an ecosystem
sort of management service and control
plane which is capable of running envoys
you can run pretty much anything that
implements these api's this might
include for example GRP CL b which is
adopting the XDS api's for client
lookaside load balancing for those
clients he'll be service measures it
could include in the future things like
hardware load balancers or other
software proxies which choose to adopt
the Envoy API is and there's an active
effort right now in the community on
making these api's structured and
version appropriately to enable
splitting off concerns which are
specific to envoy from their universal
nature another way to conceptualize this
is that this is really the analogy of
open flow of p4 for L 4 and L 7 so just
as here with an open flow you can
reconfigure let's say IP routing by an
open flow controller with with the Sdn
you can do the same with envoy and it's
data plane via XDS I just finish off
briefly by touching on the ration
shipping envoy and sto this is one of
the most famous associations between
that that exists for envoy and it
functions pretty much as a standard
sidecar proxy this is also an
interesting case study in on voice
extensibility first it's managed by the
SEO control plane called pilots over the
XDS protocols and it also features a
number of specific sto extensions that
are linked against the onboard binary to
allow to at runtime interpose an all
network traffic and funnel them to via
our pcs to the mixer service which is
part of the sto runtime and there they
can enforce additional policy checks and
logging and telemetry and so on many
folks are comfortable running envoy
themselves particularly sophisticated
users who needs use it in very custom
applications and a nice hero as well
other folks would prefer that their
envoys and astillero
service mesh control planes be managed
because these are
I think the this really like leads into
traffic director which is Google's
managed control plane for both envoy and
Sto so my colleague Arun it's gonna talk
a bit more about traffic director now so
I'll hand over to him thanks Harvey
I'm modern a software engineer at Google
so Harvey talked about how he talked
about unwind data plane and XDS API as
universal data plane API the XTS api is
often coupled with a sophisticated
control plane to drastically reduce the
operational complexity of deployments in
that context I would like to introduce
traffic director which is a globally
deployed fully GCP managed next year
server control plane to serve X J's
compliant clients like convoy traffic
director serves a network policies and
globally load balanced and centrally
health checked endpoints to the XTS
client we are the X J's API for global
load balancing traffic director has a
full view of the Lord originating from
every GCP zone and the capacity
available in every DCP zone for the
service deployed and with that knowledge
and information a traffic director has
the ability to route clients to the
closest zones with capacity and the
proximity is measured based on network
latencies and when the region is that
capacity or if there are failures in the
region a traffic director has the
ability to route clients to the closest
zones and the adjacent regions or nearby
regions the load information and the
capacity information and traffic
director is fed into autoscaler as well
so this allows autoscaler to do a
traffic demand driven auto scaling and a
sort of scalar scales up the instances a
traffic director in the interim as the
ability to route
request to a nearby zones thereby
efficiently serving the service while
the autoscaler scales up the instances
traffic director also performs
centralized cell checking so this
eliminates the need for every client in
the network to health check every other
back-end so we call it as n square
health checking and this could be a
significant source of network traffic in
your deployment finally the XDS aps are
served by traffic director via google
front-end this is the same front-end
that is used to serve other major Google
services like energy mail or search and
such so the Google Franklin has the
intelligence to route the X J's client
request to any traffic director instance
globally the task capacity and
independent of which traffic director
instance serves the request the load
balancing the global load balancing for
the client is always based on the client
zone so I want to dive a little bit
deeper into the APA model for the
traffic director the GCP API data model
is the same as HTTP lb in fact under the
hood traffic tracker uses the same
infrastructure as HTTP lb for global
load balancing and centralized tail
checking so we have a new load balancing
scheme called internal self manage that
helps direct configuration targeted for
traffic director the global forwarding
rule can in the context of traffic
director can be thought of as a
reference to a configuration for one
entity for example it may refer to a
configuration of a kubernetes service
and if the user wants to create a mesh
that is a combination of multiple
configuration the user can do that by
combining multiple forwarding rule can
fix with the same vp c network name so
in some sense the vp c network name acts
as a logical identifier for the mesh
name the URL map has the request routing
rules and action pointing to the service
represented by the backend service data
model the backends are added to the
back-end service the backends could
either be a vm represented by an instant
group data model or it could be the
container IP ports represented by a data
model called
Network endpoint groups in orchestrated
deployments like kubernetes and gke as
the endpoints get scheduled as the pods
get scheduled the network and point the
controller called net controller is
responsible for keeping the network end
point group updated so that the backend
service has the proper reflection of
endpoints to service mapping so this
allows traffic director to homogeneously
manage the VM and the container
deployments so so far we talked about
the traffic director beta features so
now I would like to introduce traffic
directors traffic control features that
are alpha or traffic control is a set of
features that helps you control the flow
of traffic in your deployment you you
could set it allows you to specify
matching rules for your incoming
requests and allows you to set up
actions for the matched request and then
at a service level per service it allows
you to set traffic policies that helps
in traffic shaping and traffic routing
the incoming request to your target
destination service not necessarily
related to traffic control but as the
number of configurations grow there
maybe need to test your configuration
through a test pool of one voice or
perhaps your mesh has on voice of
different config scope and in such cases
you can potentially use a configuration
filtering option where you can target
the configuration to a subset of or
noise identified through their metadata
ok so let me dive a little deeper into
each of these features for a request
matching for set of rules to specify on
what to match for the incoming request
you can set up a host match you can set
up a path match and there are variants
like prefix match suffix match and
regular expressions and so on or
can set up matches based on anything in
your header like you know cookies user
agents and so on and once a match is
found you can perform certain actions on
the matched requests the standard
actions are redirects rewrites header
transforms or sending the traffic to a
particular service but I want to talk
about few interesting use cases and the
actions so let's say you have a binary
that you want a cannery or you have a
monolithic binary and you're starting to
have container or modernize your
application by container raising it and
going to a micro service model you can
use an action or traffic action called
traffic splitting where you can set up a
small percentage of traffic to go to
your new deployment or the new binary
and over time as he qualified the binary
as you get more confidence you can send
more and more traffic to the new binary
enabling a smooth transition so let's
say you want to understand the
resilience resiliency of your micro
service when one of your coal dependency
starts responding with errors you can
set up an action called fault injection
where you can specify thresholds and
type of errors that your service would
respond with and using that you can
figure out you know how your deployment
behaves in the presence of those errors
so we even at Google we have needs where
we have test pair and test but service
and instead of using synthetic or
simulated traffic sometimes there is a
need to have production traffic and test
out your you know test binaries you know
to do that you can do something called
traffic mirroring where you can use the
traffic control features to set up
traffic to be mirrored - a shadow
service without impacting your
production deployments and this shadow
service could be your test service in
your testbed helping to qualify or test
binary with production traffic so we
talked about traffic directors global
load balancing so the global load
balancing helps pick out a zone with
capacity
however there may be needs for the user
to set up more fine-grained load
balancing schemes so we allow a purser
with load balancing configuration that
influences how a back-end is picked
within a zone while the global load
balancing picks out the zone with
capacity so that this two-tiered load
balancing enables you to have options
like in a round-robin or weighted round
robin or affinity and such and fine tune
your load balancing schemes while still
leveraging the global load balancing
offered by traffic director so on to the
final slide so as a service owner if you
would want to have a good control of the
volume of connections open from a client
to your service you can set up something
called circuit breakers which is a way
to apply back pressure on the client and
have the clients fail fast rather than
overwhelm your clients or sorry or arm
your backends oftentimes it takes a
small amount of time for the control
plane to turn around with a globally
optimal decision however if you want a
better resiliency in your data plane
where if a particular back-end instance
goes down or a VM goes down and if you
want to respond to that quickly before
the control plane can detect the state
of our change in the health state of the
backends
you can set up something called outlier
detection where in the data plane you
identify unresponsive backends and Evek
those back ends until the control plane
turns around with a globally optimal
decision okay so with that I'm gonna
pass the presentation over to Larry
who's going to talk about an interesting
mesh use case and modernization of telco
infrastructure good thank you
so now that you understand service
meshes I'm going to break it or at least
challenge it with a different use case
which is the telco use case so you need
to have a picture in your head which is
it's a multi cloud world and of course
we know there are a lot of data center
public clouds if you probably also know
that there are intermediate clouds they
they live in ix it they live within the
telcos and living in an exchange points
and the current push is I'm sure you're
aware you've been following the hype is
towards the edge so the question is how
what is exactly going to happen here as
we get out to the edge and how are we
going to do service meshes across this
entire thing now this particular picture
is a little bit aspirational because it
shows a really nice clean edge that the
truth of the matter is there's a lot of
legacy hardware at the edge right now
and of course it depends on whose edge
we're talking about but I'm going to
talk about the Teleco edge for a minute
so these are the central offices at the
telco it's the head ends of the cable
companies and if you were ever to go
inside of one of those you'd think you
had walked into a museum because it's
full of hardware that goes back many
many years as long as it's generating
money they keep it running you might
find 300 different kinds of hardware
devices inside of a telco central office
and so it's clearly in this in the
telcos best interest to try to modernize
that that infrastructure and so what
they've been doing is they've been
trying to commoditize virtualize and
desegregate the access network and by
access network I'm talking about the
cellular network and the fibre to the
home the passive optical networks and so
they're working hard at this they
basically are trying to adopt the same
technology that's back in the public
cloud and apply it to these edges full
of these specialized devices there's a
project at the onf that we're involved
with called cord which is an umbrella
but it also is a particular
implementation which is an acronym for
central office we architected as a data
center but the idea is to take those
commodity virtualize type technologies
and bring them to the edge and so that's
well in progress a lot of disaggregation
has happened it's being put back
together again and that does in fact get
us to the point that I'm gonna call this
thing the access edge because it's a
point where traditional conventional
cloud technology and access technology
Co exists and so that's the end this is
call it the access edge
of course from a telecoil you they are
interested in offering services to
subscribers so we have to think at a
little bit finer granularity every now
and then in terms none of us service
mesh but as a service chain and in the
near future that service chain is going
to be distributed across the access edge
some intermediate telco clouds or
internet exchange points all the way
back up into the data center and it will
in fact go onto the premises as well so
there will be an on-premises aspect to
the to the edges in addition to the
access edge but one of the unique things
about the access network is that it's
also supports mobility and so these
service chains need to be able to
migrate from one edge to another which
as you move functionality closer to the
edges means that that functionality has
to move as well so if you pull back for
a second and think about the earlier
generations of the of the cellular
network to G 4G and for two 4G it's
basically mobility of the broadband
access but now if we're gonna move
functionality to the edge we have to
move the functions as well that doesn't
mean VM migration but somehow I have to
support the fact that you had something
running on your behalf at one edge and
it may now need to run another edge so
in effect the cloud becomes mobile as
well as as the broadband connectivity so
this is the big picture of what the
telco world is after and that is to be
part of the part of this end-to-end
cloud environment so they had to start
from the beginning you all know micro
services because you've been breaking
your monolithic applications down for a
long time the telecom industry is just
now trying to do that so I wanted to
spend just a couple minutes talking
about that because it's after you break
it down that you get to put it back
together in a service mesh well so these
like I said these central offices are
full for private Airy closed bundled
hardware and it's another alphabet soup
and if you know any of these good for
you but in the access networks we've got
ponds and rands and E you know B's and B
and E's and so on not important what
those all are that's the it's the
various boxes and again they're
monolithic closed pieces of hardware and
they're being disaggregated and so part
of that disaggregation is to split the
control plane from the data plane this
is Stan
Sdn practices part of is to break the
monolithic pieces of code into
microservices so that's what the rest of
the cloud industry is doing but the
other thing that's kind of interesting
here is because first and foremost there
are communication services running
sometimes you want to take those micro
services and drop them down into the
switching fabric and so because the data
plane intz in modern white box which is
also programmable I can take what used
to run on a micro service and move it
down and into the forwarding plane now
we're talking the hardware forwarding
plane so these are all aspects of
disaggregation ok it's not just micro
services it's programming the forwarding
plane in the in the switches as well
well let me just try to make it slightly
more concrete so this is now a service
smash this without going through the
details of how you break down any
particular bit of hardware this is a
service message for the seller use case
and again there's a bunch of acronyms
what's important about the color coding
here is that everything in blue is a
function that's implemented in the
switching fabric everything that's right
is a function that's implemented on my
in a container in a micro service the
solid lines are data paths packets
actually flow over on behalf of n
subscribers the dotted lines are control
control paths and this is clearly an
opportunity to bring traditional service
mesh technology to bear so we could run
envoy on the video archive and the CDN
out at the edge the other thing to note
is that this is in fact also multi cloud
so bits and pieces of it and they could
they can be configured in different ways
but bits and pieces of it here will in
fact run at the access edge and pieces
of it will run back in perhaps commodity
cloud so this is a configuration that
we've been working on in conjunction
with the service mesh world and and the
UNF to try to demonstrate this in the
cellular case oh and by the way this is
just representative in the in the sense
that we assume there will be other edge
services and by the way those edge
services are the ones that need
high-bandwidth low-latency and deal with
a scalable number of Internet of Things
or whatever autonomous vehicles are out
there at the edge and there will course
be multiple cloud services running back
in the data center as well
okay so we've blown these things into
bits now we have to put them back
together again and this is for something
like a service miss is an important tool
but operationalizing this disaggregated
system is a little bit different than
simply connected together a bunch of
micro services because there are other
elements in here so I wanted to walk
through that for just a few minutes so I
think if this is the disruptors dilemma
and this is in fact the critical problem
that the telco industry is facing right
now on the one hand they wanted to
disaggregate everything because that's
what Spurs innovation I've got smaller
pieces it's not tightly bundled and
controlled by the vendors that's that is
in fact the value proposition of open
networking and Sdn on the other hand you
can't deploy a bunch of disaggregated
components you have to you have to
integrate them back together again now
in the telco world because what they're
used to doing is dropping in these
bundled solutions they have a certain
mindset as to how that integration
happens basically they take the
disaggregated components and then
repackage them until there are
monolithic solution again and then
that's what they're prepared to drop in
that kind of defeats the purpose you're
not you're not doing continuous
integration of the individual components
if you if you fall but back to that kind
of hard-coded integration and so what
the key focus here is that they also
automate the the integration process and
so that involves a declarative intent I
basically this is very much in the
spirit of service meshes I want to lift
the operator parameter operational
parameters out of the services and up
into a service control plane leaving
behind the implementation of the service
proper so I separate the development
concerns for the operational deployment
concerns I want to avoid those
hard-coded dependencies between the the
pieces that I've just carved off second
and consistent with that I want to
centralized Authority I don't want to
have to go touch 80 pieces of code every
time I make a change I want to centrally
declare this is my intent and then make
it so everywhere else otherwise I'm
gonna end up instead of managing 300 I'm
gonna be managing 30,000 different micro
services and and the segregated
components in the central offices that's
not a good place to be the third point
is we have to be implementation agnostic
and this is the this is really critical
because it's not just micro services
there's going to be fun
action ality implemented in brownfield
hardware devices for some time they're
gonna be functions implemented in
virtual machines they're gonna be micro
services and there's going to be
functions that are implemented in the
switching fabric and so we can't bake
assumptions into our service control
plane about where things are implemented
so the solution that we have come to as
of now and what we're deploying in
trials within the major carriers that
are partners of the UNF just a to words
about the own F our partners are our
network operators and that's a broadly
defined term Google's a member AT&T
Comcast don't you telecom and so on so
the ones that want to see this happen
and the set of vendors that are
supporting them to try to make it happen
but in that setting we are putting
together solutions and we have a service
control plane that's called X OS and the
important thing to take away from it is
that it's basically managing a service
data plane that has a collection of
different disaggregated components that
it's managing some of those are legacy
virtual network functions running an VM
some of them are horizontally scalable
micro services and some of them are Sdn
control apps and others are possible as
well they could have been legacy SAS for
that matter and it's a very declarative
way you tell you give X OS a schema that
says this is how I want all of these
parts glued together in a logical space
make it so down on the data plane so
it's a very consistent model of what
happens with service meshes now having
positive that let's step back for a
second and hopefully you've recognized
the parallels here it's the same story
different level and so the parallels are
at l7 we have a programmable data plane
it's programmed in proxies in l2 l3 it's
programming the Asics in the in the
switches we have an API it's XDS in the
l7 case it's either open flow or p4
runtime both are both happen in the in
the cord case and the control plane we
have something like is do in the cord
case we have something like Ono's which
is an open network operating system so
think of whatever your favorite Sdn
controller is and substitute it there or
the way you'll notice I left out l4 l4
could be solved in either one of those I
did
want to put it in either one as the
absolute right answer but l4 is clearly
where the two or the two meet
so if you if you apply that basic
mapping of the world back on to where we
are with the service mesh you finds an
obvious parallel between ohno-san sto
and envoy is a way of programming the
data plane in the same way that we can
use P for people our runtime to program
this switching the switching fabric and
therefore affect the data plane now that
kind of leaves us a little bit of a
struggle as to what we call these things
because I've just added an extra level
here so this is a kiss is a control
plane does that make this the management
plane that is certainly one
interpretation but the interpretation
that I prefer is to say that we have a
network control plane and we have a
service control plane and the difference
is perhaps subtle but perhaps important
which is at the service level we do also
keep track of state for the services
that are inside of the the grey boxes at
the bottom and that's really critical
because we're not just managing a set of
Micra services or managing the
functionality on behalf of subscribers
and this actually gets us to one of the
challenging problems in the telco case
which I think's has some applicability
to these two service messes in general
which is that if this were a service
mash and that's just an arbitrary one
except again I've color-coded it so that
there are micro service based services
and there are switch based services then
I have on behalf of different
subscribers or classes of subscribers
something called a service chain which
is an Alec and instance of each one of
those services let's assume they are
multi-tenant services on behalf of a
particular subscriber that gives me a
path through the service mesh on behalf
of that particular subscriber and I have
another service chain perhaps it's
different that runs on behalf of another
subscriber so in the networking world
this is sometime in the access network
role this is sometimes called network
slicing but I can give you some
guaranteed service and I didn't give you
customized functionality on on a
subscriber
my subscriber basis or perhaps on a
subscriber class my subscriber class
patient basis this is really critical
for monetizing the edge as you might
imagine is a pretty important thing but
as we roll out as the telcos roll out 5g
the ability to control at that kind of
granularity and not only provide control
at that granularity but also Diagnostics
at that granularity and troubleshooting
that that granularity is a critical
requirement so managing runtime
workflows it's not just about
configuration parameters it's not just
saying here's how I want you to behave
go for it it's it's it's a runtime
operation as well so the key takeaways
first of all the access network is being
codified it is being reduced to
commodity software virtualization
disaggregation the integration challenge
is the hard one and that's the same
that's the same challenge that service
meshes are targeted at some of the
specifics are a little bit different but
at the end of the day these service
meshes I believe will span both access
networks on-premises and back into the
public cloud the second big point that
access networks will be part of the
multi cloud there's a really really
interesting question here as to who's
gonna own the edge and in fact if you
look at the the two-count counter
industries here in terms of the cloud
clearly moving towards the edge in terms
of the the incumbent service providers
already at the edge with the footprint
in the central offices they're clearly
trying to turn that into a small edge
cloud and move back upstream so there is
a collision course happening here I have
no idea how the dust is going to settle
but I do believe access technology is
going to be at a critical part of that
future multi cloud because it's gonna be
a critical part of the edge and that's
simply because of the the capabilities
at 5g will eventually bring us there's a
whole lot of value that's potential
there above and beyond just thinking
everything at the edge is gonna be Wi-Fi
that's actually the sub-points get into
that this is certainly going to be part
of the telecom infrastructure but I
think it's more importantly also going
to be democratized and part of the
on-premises infrastructure at the same
time there's there is
unlicensed ban that's gonna be available
for 5g in the US and starting to happen
in Europe putting these into man you
putting these capabilities into
manufacturing plants parking lots and
any any time you try to how to make
drones or whatever that's going to be a
critical part of it as a and therefore
it's this entrant and it's because of
this intrinsic support for mobility low
latency and scaleable number of edge
devices that this is going to be
critical
the final bulletin is I do believe that
service meshes will be the unifying
abstraction we already are making good
progress in two different settings the
telco one is is a slightly different one
and that's slightly newer one but I
think it's it's going to these are gonna
merge we clearly need to model services
and not just serve a simple and be
agnostic about the surface
implementation when I say service in
this room you immediately probably think
kubernetes service but we have to think
more broadly than that second support
for fine-grain workflows at runtime is
going to be a critical requirement and
there are clearly parallels between what
we're doing at l3 l2 l3 and L 7 we need
to figure out I think in fact it
probably comes back to what is the
language with which or the API with
which I control this the the data plane
no matter what level I'm at because
we're gonna find that functionality
moving up and down the stack for
performance reasons and for generality
reasons all the time and that's where we
need to get ourselves to
[Applause]
[Music]